okay hello everybody I'm I'm really glad
many people are excited about colors so
it's not only me so just like to give
you a short introduction of the idea of
that hog like this year in spring I went
to the Hannover fair like the format's a
bit and like all the companies that
they're having their cool dashboards and
they all looked horrible and was like
yeah maybe somebody should tell them
what they're doing wrong
so I came up with that idea I'm for talk
so I'm Danielle and I work in a small
consultant company called uncouth IT and
I'm also like as you see with the color
of my t-shirt one of the organizers of
Paideia Berlin so really happy to have
that many people here and I hope we have
some really cool Dacia so I'm like I
don't have that much time so just to
give like a short introduction like I
want to talk a little bit about color
theory like the history some important
people well you probably know most of
them I will talk a little bit about like
Halloween so like it will be pretty
hopefully a lot of the slides said will
be something pleasing to watch I will
talk a little bit about color models and
then give you some like psychology
background and give you some like ideas
on the route so like it's not that easy
to choose good colors in general so I
just want to like give you some ideas
where to get started and like what
really to avoid and I will end with some
do's and don'ts to give get you like
some ideas what to do
so like first of all like to get started
like I want all of you to think about
like what is a color and to like try to
describe the color for example green
with our examples of objects that are
green and then you will maybe realize
it's quite a difficult to describe what
green is if you don't can come up with
examples and that's because I culled as
a really abstract concept in general so
yeah like if you think about back in
school you probably know those charts
about like human colon cells and how we
are the humans see colors and they were
like we're just like wavelength and we
have those three different cone cells
for colors for like short medium and
long wavelength and this is kind of how
we as human and see colors
and this is just like a short recap to
get you an idea I'm this dashed line are
it's like a different cone cell which is
only there for like darkness but not for
color but yeah like this is kind of like
how it works in human brain and like
we'll see some of those references later
and just now to be aware of like the
connection of red and and green is quite
important later on so to get started
like what is color theory like why is it
quite a cool topic in my opinion it's
like first of all it's a science and
it's an art so it's kind of something
like changing like it's something but
like a personal preference and taste so
it makes it quite exciting that's not
always I could write all wrong it's
always something to to negotiate it's a
lot about a human perception like not
everybody sees the same like this is
also quite interesting in that field and
we'll talk about it later a little bit
about psychology and the field is also
about like color mixing where you see
the connection to art like to mix colors
together for painting for example it's
about communication and also like Halle
theory also describes method to
replicate colors for example in
different settings if you think about
like printing a page it should look like
the way it looks on your computer so I
give used color theory and all that all
the time
so like to start really back in the day
it's like just give you like some short
introduction like really important
people in that field and the first one
being as toddlers who was a Greek
philosopher and he wrote a book like
basically the first known book about
color called the collage Ibis which is
which just means like on colors and his
concept of colors were that like all
colors come from like white lightness
and dark subtract like black color which
is quite good
in a wave like we understand light now
to the like light it's like white light
is basically the full spectrum and like
you see a lot of people connect colors
to something like like they take a like
C and he used the four elements water
air earth and fire to connect it to the
colors so like he created it's like
first basic color palette with like some
different colors
and yeah like if we go way later
probably nobody heard of like Leon
Albert II who was like in quite famous
Italian architect and now we think like
yeah like an architect what does he have
to do what colors and he was doing a lot
of like theoretical work in general and
he wrote a book called deep dig to her
which means on painting she wrote like a
guideline book for painting and it was a
lot about perspective composition and
colors so he did not really like he was
also painter a little bit but didn't
really get that successful so I guess he
was not that good but he defined that
like black and white are not colors
which is also quite interesting in a way
that we see it now and who made like big
use of all the stuff he was writing in
that book but like not really able to to
like practice was Oh first of all yeah
he came up in that book with color
mixing so it was also like the first guy
ever to like mix colors together in a
book to like show how you can like
create new colors with mixing colors
together and yeah like what I said
before like you probably all know like
da Vinci and he really used all the
theory in that book from Albert II and
you said for like training his paintings
for like many beliefs like I like the
best paintings ever created by by
humankind and yeah like he used all that
concept of colors and perspective and
composition in his book so like he
really like made practice out of the the
concepts that Albert he was doing and
then yeah I guess Isaac Newton is like
another guy was really influential and
like maybe the most influential
scientists ever and yeah you probably
all know like his prism experiment like
like worst of all from the piping of
Pink Floyd cover on the left so I don't
know how many of you remember that the
original experiment had two prisms so
the left one were like white light
passes through the prism and it breaks
into the whole spectrum of colors so
like which is basically the Pink Floyd
cover but then in his experiment he also
the second prism where only one of those
colors was going through and he needed
that to conclude that the prison does
not alter or like change the color that
goes through
it it will just yeah like spread the
white light into old of all the possible
colors so like you needed that second
second proven as well and what he did
then like we just like you know middle
line with all those colors was he was
the first guy to like come up with a
color wheel and like we'll see a couple
of those now like I created the right
one just for you to show because it's
only in black and white and what is
quite interesting here is like the
number of colors that you choose on your
color wheel is quite arbitrary like it
just depends on like your personal
preference or like what do you see and
what's quite interesting here is like
before we are seeing like colors that
were mapped to the four elements of the
earth he mapped colors to musical
intervals it's like two CD and like all
of those which you can kind of see on
the on the on the left here so that's
also like a quite interesting connection
in my opinion to like again combine kind
of science and art into one field then
like we have Johann Shiva Miller who was
an Australian naturalist and he was the
first guy to come up with this
continuous color wheel so he combined
all those colors into something like
more continuously like the way we use it
now he came up with those like twelve
colors like if you can read German you
can maybe see that and also what he was
working on was like in addition to that
picture that you see here he described
the table with 81 shades of the color
will get soon to like what a shade is
like my definition but it gets quite
interesting and here you see a real big
connection to to art and painting and
Moses Harris was like another guy like
an English guy who wrote a book that
took him like quite a while or like
seven years and in that book he um he
talked a lot about like Calla mixing
also like whitey like artistic mindset
and like what I want to point out like I
don't know how many of you have seen
that picture which is quite famous if
you see if you look in the middle you
just was like three and triangles of
blue yellow and just like reddish color
which were like his main colors did he
use and if you check in the middle where
all those colors overlap it creates some
kind of shade of black so like we'll see
that later and some different color
models so like he was
the first guy to come up with like that
idea and like his ideas just to help
artists to create colors for their
painting but like we still use some of
that stuff now then some guy you
probably did not expect years like I
don't know how many of your German but
like you probably all know Goethe from
like being a writer like really
successful in addition to that he was
also like a statesman like you worked in
politics he was a scientist as well and
an artist and he wrote a really
important book called the theory of
colors which was a lot about the human
color perception and he was also like a
big painter like he was painting a lot
of pictures are quite good which I guess
many people really don't know so he
created this like six color color wheel
that you see here in that book and
that's like a few things that are quite
special here so first of all he was the
first guy who recognized how important
and magenta is and if you think about
printing you still have like magenta
print so he was the first guy who really
understand the importance of that color
and like it's quite difficult to read
like even if you read German but in that
color wheel he put in some attributes to
color so like he gave them some kind of
like feeling what they what they say so
in that example like he said yellow is
yellow is good and the green is useful
and he says like violet is unnecessary
so it's quite like you know random like
his personal taste but it's quite
interesting if you think about like
Holub psychology and what colors do and
she also came up with a concept of warm
colors and cool colors and we'll see
that later again but I think that's
quite cool so maybe he combined it's
like poetic mind said what colors and
like created all those combinations in
an earlier study he also had a color
wheel where you had some like occupation
and character traits that he met two
colors so like melancholic being like
reddish colors for example
so I guess quite quite interesting in in
that way and yeah like another German
guy like Philip Unger he was like a
paint pen pal with Goethe so they both
worked on colors in a way and he was the
first guy who put like a
mention into into those color wheels so
like now we don't have a color wheel
anymore we have this color a sphere and
on the top two you see the two poles of
its like he had three three main colors
which were like yellow red and blue and
then on the top of the of the pole you
see like the white the white poles and
under on the right here you see a black
so the two bottom pictures here just
like if you cut that that like all
horizontally or vertically and this just
creates like way more ideas what you can
do what colors they like create like
many new many new shades so like who
took that on the next level
was Albert Mansell who was an American
painter and teacher of art and what he
did develop was is basically still D
like effective standard in America so
like he took the ideas and like really
made him into like scientific and came
up with like some some concept and he
defined three dimensions which you can
see here we'll see those like
differently like those terms later again
like in more detail just to give you an
idea of like the color system that he he
created quite important such as a ring
of colors where you see five main colors
like blue and green and then you have
five colors in between like this like
blue green and green yellow that you see
like one is like ring around it which he
defined is being to you and then like
you see from the top to the bottom just
like grayish colors from black to gray
to white and then if you go from inside
the cube to the outside there's a value
called chroma which is something like
these like color strengths like how
strong that color is so like we'll talk
about those like terms later but like
this is just something really important
to like define and colors and when we
talk about color models so um if we go
back a little bit more to be like
artistic side like I don't know how many
of you heard about power house well like
it's a quite special year right now for
like a hundred year anniversary so if
you're longer to learn they're cool
museums to check out and like Bauhaus is
mainly about architecture design but
also about colors and like I will just
focus on
Cullens here so your Honda sittin was
the Swiss artist and like he was a
teacher in this like Bauhaus school and
he wrote a book called the art of color
where he created this kind of color
wheel here so he was the first guy to
talk about primary secondary and
tertiary colors that you see here being
like this we in main colors in the
middle there's like triangular shaped
things like red blue and yellow and if
you mix two primary colors you get a
secondary color and then like tertiary
colors mixed with like primary and
secondary colors so um he defined those
concepts and I guess like still many
people use and you often like read and
hear about in that in that field yeah
one of his students was Jonas Albers
who's on like a German artist and he
later was also teaching in the Bauhaus
school and he wrote a book that's called
and the interaction of color
it was just playing around with
different colors and their effect if he
put them next to each other like the
first like print of that book was quite
limited and they had like 150 like
colored silk plates in it too to play
around on your own so it was quite quite
something new and I guess it book is now
available as an iPad app if you want to
play around with it but mainly that book
was talking about the relativity of
color which like some color looks
different like those two brownish
rectangles here have the same color they
just look different like not that much
here but like much more on my my
computer which is like perfectly on the
field yeah and like what he is most
famous for is this like art serious call
to homage to the squares like I don't
know how many museums you went to like
maybe you've seen some of those and
where he just puts in like nested
squares together with like different
colors and you create some like really
cool chromatic interaction with that and
I guess like now this is kind of the
question like is this art was this
science so I guess like this is like
always is really interesting like
connection to it and like those pieces
were sold for like one to two million
dollars so I guess it's quite good for
an artist like maybe not science in that
way but it definitely has some
scientific value
so yeah so like really make it quick
like just to talk quickly about some
definitions that you often see in that
field so you get a better idea like
after today what people are talking
about if they use some terms I just try
to focus on the really important ones
here so if you're like tint tone and
shade this is quite an easy concept in
general so like if you take your pure
color like blue on the right and you mix
pure white to it
it's called tint if you mix pure black
into it it's a shade and if you put in
any shade of grey it's it is a tone so
it's just like three terms that I guess
I just used quite often interchangeably
but like they just define something
really really different and that we've
seen you already like the ring on the
Munsell color model that we have seen so
you is basically just a pure color and a
special part of you is a letter like
specified as an angle so you have it
like zero and 360 degrees you have red
at 120 you have green and at 240 you
have a blue but you can specify any pure
color here on this like dimension I
guess like many people know like
saturation which is just some like like
color intensity so on the left you can
either mix white black or some kind of
grey into it so on the left you will
have like some shade of that and then
like you go more into the pure color so
like on the right you have like 100 100
percent of the pure color that we've
seen I'm on the you dimension and then
what's getting a little bit more tricky
what you seen before like the chroma
it's kind of like similar to like
saturation and all those concepts are
kind of related to each other so that
makes it a little bit difficult in my
opinion you understand so when when we
talk about chroma we talked about the
perceived strength of a color so what do
you see here maybe is like on the left
we have like 100% white on the right we
have 100% the color or black and then in
the middle we have those shades of color
or shades of gray and they all have the
same lightness so this is a really
important part here like you create some
like lightness into into that dimension
and yeah just to finish it up with
something like a little bit more complex
on the chart
really easy to understand it's like the
two concepts for lightness add value
which are really similar and almost the
same so it gets really important here is
to understand like you have two charts
here we have two colors like cyan and
red next to each other which are like
180 degrees or like zero degrees in he
you and then on the columns we see
saturation from 1 to 0 and then from 0
to 1 again for the two colors and then
what I want to show you here is
basically just like if you go the rows
up and down which is like on the Left we
see lightness and on the right we see
value so if you if you just want to try
to like find the pure color you will see
50% of lightness is the pure color and
100% of lightness is just a white light
like makes sense on that in that way
value on the other side just like skips
that into half so like on 100% of value
you get the full pure color so whatever
you have like 50% valued it's the same
as 100% of lightness it's like they all
I got together and like different
systems like different color models use
like different of those concepts so yeah
if you talk about color models I guess
you all know RGB and CMYK and so just to
give you like a really like short idea
like RGB and CMYK being like color
models like over kind of different kind
and the color model is always some kind
of like abstract mathematical model and
we have additive color models so you see
on the on the left so you start with
like darkness like black and then you
add light colors switch to create like
new colors and this is basically what
you see everywhere unlike your phone
your TV your computer screen if you have
like a black surface and you put colors
on top of it and on the right like an a
subtractive color model is just the
opposite you start with lightness like
like blank sheet of paper and then you
absorb light by putting colors on it and
you mix those together to create new
colors and like this is kind of a
concept it's also used for like painting
like you start with something like like
a playing surface yeah and then like you
always like just when you go to
computers you you probably notice like
try pools of of colors like for example
this RGB try blood which you can
visualize as this cue
so like it's kind of like a position in
that cube so like wherever you are in
that you can specify with that location
and then all the color like models you
normally have like three or four
different values maybe you have like
seeing those color models with the Alpha
Channel to give you some opacity as well
this is all like to to like create the
same color on different devices so like
this is like another like color model
like HSL which is basically hue
saturation and lightness and that was
developed in the 70s guess it's not
really used anymore but like it's just
like more advanced now just to give you
an idea like how that looks kind of in
just like cylindrical shape of like you
on the outside saturation from inside
with your out and lightness from top to
the bottom and then like online you will
see all those like color pickers and
like for the different programs that you
use it will like look a little bit
different but you can just like use
different color models like you see it's
like RGB and HSL so like you can
recalculate it and like different color
models are better for like different
colors than others but like it's always
some kind of drawback on others so just
to talk slightly about human perception
of colors like here you should all see
like if you just take the same color we
are quite sensitive to green light so
like even though we have to like the
same linear shade of color we see here
like we we see green as more light than
red and red more light and blue this is
just because of like human like like
cone cells do not work the same as we
like trench sight and feels like some
color models so this is just something
really important to to like realize in
the human eye may not be perfect for
like some kind of computer model that
you see on the other side I'm like ever
said before they all like a concept that
we talked about all I kind of connected
and related to each other so we also
have just like saturation lightness
dependency which is quite interesting to
see like if you see the you like which
is just a ring of it and like on the
left we have like a low lightness it
goes up on the right and the saturation
from the inside to the outside and we
just see like something like a dark
yellow is something we can't really see
and on the other side like if you check
the they're like blueish
and purple like we can see just a lot of
like middle and like high saturated
colors and some others may not be that
good and yeah then coming back to good
her like warm and cool colors which like
he defined as the first first person
like warm colors being something we see
as like daylight or like sunset maybe
and cold colors being like kind of
connected to like some gray overcast day
or something and this is like highly
depends on you culturing influence so I
get different cultures colors means
something different so this is just
something to be really aware of and like
the whole field of like color biology is
just used a lot in like marketing and
branding so if you check like company
logos and they normally have really good
people they're like especially the big
companies if you see some small
companies you see some horrible logos
and like horrible color choices and they
all want to like tell you something I
get some really cool stuff on the
internet if you were like interested in
like branding and marketing so I get
those colors like mean something so like
you should be aware of that if you
choose colors for your chart as well so
yeah I guess like to just like wrap that
all up into like some really easy points
for you to like take take along on a
road I created some really important
parts here and then I have some do's and
don'ts in the end and then I hope you
all learn a lot to like make better
charts in the short amount of time like
you know I can't tell you like those are
the colors you should use it really
depends but I hope you know after that
like what it is like how you can get
started easily so like the first point
being like don't use color if you don't
have to like just try to make it gray I
found this really cool article which is
called make gray your best friend which
I really recommend all of you to read
it's really cool written like they have
some nice examples and it's basically
about like you should use as much grey
as possible and you should use color
only to highlight what is important so I
guess is an example of that blog so like
I would really recommend everybody
reading that blog post till I get an
idea and yeah just use less colors in
general it's just a really big advice I
can give everybody here
second being like youth different
colorful different data
so like here you just see some like
color harmonies or like something like
pleasing and like aesthetically pleasing
colors that go well together but
depending on your data and your problem
you should be aware of like you should
maybe use different colors that there
may be like only opposite of the wheel
or may be next to each other so like
depends if you have like categorical
data and diverging data or sequential
data like you should use colors that
like go well with the data that you have
at hand this is also like just something
really important like if you just use
default colors it will mainly just like
some really false consequences in like
what you think that means
next being like use intuitive colors if
you can also like not always that easy
like you just see like a world map with
some like to like color maps here of
like blueish and greenish colors being
like green for the land and blue for the
water if you would turn it around like I
bet seeing that image will take like
three seconds for you to understand it's
like the globe or something it's just
sometimes really difficult and yeah like
just try to make something that sense
for speaking of that also like you're
always in - for safe there's like
traffic signals like this is just
horrible in general but like you know
like that goes into like being intuitive
like it's not always that easy to to
choose good colors for that yeah like
what I mentioned before like think about
like human perception of colors like
they create some kind of feeling there's
like a lot of like warm and cool colors
like that may go too well together or
not and think about like some cultural
influence like just different colors I
mean just something completely different
like here I guess again in Europe with
the sea like red has lost exciting maybe
like some danger but like in different
countries I could just mean something
completely completely different so like
think about your audience like who will
see that shot later um yeah then like
another point which I think most people
never do like included me it's like
think about missing values like if you
have some like null values like non data
and you just put it in there like that
you see on the left
you may come to the conclusion by just
looking at it that you have some data
values for water whereas if you would
execute it and like makes it visible
like on the right you will just see
better yeah like there's no data in it
like just to like something to think
about
and like I think the left one is
prettier but it's maybe more wrong so
like I guess this is like a really
interesting field here that you see and
then yeah color blindness that I haven't
mentioned so far so like I was reading
like around 5% of humans are at least
partially colorblind like I don't know
how many can see that so it's just
something to be aware of like many
people like what I said before like
traffic lights for example yeah I'm like
green and red or like just like normal
your colors this is just often really
bad choice because like if like one out
of 20 is not able to see your chart
anymore like this is quite a lot it's
like it depends I guess on the audience
as well but it's quite easy to like
choose colors which colorblind people
can can can see as well so it's just not
really a lot of effort for you but it
will just make it easier for everybody
else
so like another really practical tip for
everybody here like I don't know who
heard of the color Brewer which is I
take one minute to create colors for
your like specific problem and
everybody's happy like it's a really
easy website to use like you specify
just like how many classes do you have
what kind of data do you have like we
have categories - yes um like I'm
diverging all a qualitative data and
then you can like see immediately how it
looks like you can choose you can like
choose some options to make like print
friendly and I'm colorblind safe so it's
like really it takes one minute and you
can just export that into your Python
notebook or like some other tools like
that makes it just really really easy to
choose colors so like that's like what I
would recommend everybody like everybody
has one minute to spend on a chart like
I would say like there many other tools
available I just think this is the
easiest to get started and the easiest
to to like create quick colors for your
visualization so yeah to finish it up
like just some more do's and downs in
like a little bit more general and then
I included tons of links here so like if
you
like read more about all of that like
darlings here so I guess they're like a
lot to do so like to do first of all
like take your time like if if you
create charts like just don't like take
the first of all I don't use those
default colors just take some time to to
create your charts and label the charts
like really put in like labels on the
axes give it a title and I think it
nobody really puts text on to charts
anymore which i think is quite bad
because even yourself you see your own
chart three weeks later and you have no
idea what you did so just adding some
text like some description or it will
just make it easier for everybody and
then this just is new concept like I
don't know how many of you here work
with tableau about like storytelling and
those like tablo's and masters which are
quite good at it it's like just they
think about the data with some questions
and answers in their mind and to create
some like story which just makes it easy
for people to to understand so I'll give
you interested in storytelling just
Google tableaus and masters and you will
find like a lot of cool visualization
stories that really answer questions
that you didn't have before then also
like what I didn't talk about here's
like chart types so like there's many
different chart types um there's a
really cool tool from the Financial
Times
they're included in the links which is
like a public tableau dashboard about
chart types like we didn't have time for
that but like think about what chart
type is good for you to use and I guess
it really depends on a problem if you
don't have those examples but just some
raw data it may not be the trivial to
like choose which chart type you want to
want to use there like the more complex
your charts get maybe it's a good idea
to sketch first like if you spend like
one or two days and like making the
chart look like it should and then
somebody tells you like yeah like that's
not what I had in mind that's maybe
easier to like sketch first to see what
what may happen for easy charts I guess
it's not possible but if you grant those
like fancy and Sankey plots or something
like that it makes sense to first sketch
it to get a better idea if it even works
yeah as I said before I use as much gray
as possible use color only to highlight
what's really important like what people
should see and like see immediately like
what
should take along under way then on
general I call those like charts that
like have access always start at zero
it's super confusing if you don't but it
depends of course on the audience but
like just in general is just something
really unintuitive to do you should
think about handling your missing values
to some extent like if you don't think
about it it will just do something that
you may not be aware of and so it's just
a good idea to like think about it or
like just exclude it from the data but
like think about it before you do it
think about your audience as well like
if it's small audience it may be a
little bit more complex it may be okay
as a guideline I would say check
newspapers or like magazines like The
Economist or the New York Times and the
charts that they are using are normally
good for like a big audience and they
also have really good people in doing
that with like colors charts so I guess
like this is just like always a good
inspiration to get from like getting
some really good shots and yeah like
learn MATLAB like I know it's horrible
the syntax is really confusing I try to
do it but like it's really really
difficult just a lot of Python libraries
are based on my pot lips so at some
point if you want to do something really
specific you need to write map on that
code and then it becomes just handy to
know it but I know it's really awful and
it's a lot but in general it's just like
really helpful to know the more better
yeah and I just like made a last-minute
change of like you're talking about
charts not including that one I don't
know if you move you know stare chart or
B all of them know even okay some many
people say this is the best chart ever
from me not who was like visualizing the
March from Napoleon to like Moscow so he
put in here like six or seven dimensions
I guess into two and I guess there's
like some stuff you can improve like
first of all like his handwriting is
quite awful I guess but just to give you
an idea of like you know like there's a
lot of text here to explain so like what
do you see here is like the troops going
from like like France to like Moscow you
see the size of the troop you see how
many like the black line how many are
wounded and I go back you see the dates
you see the location you see the
temperature and line on the bottom just
to give you some idea like
how do charts look like if they're good
and I just put it in here for the text
because I think nobody puts text into
charts anymore and they should do more
and yeah just some like don'ts don't use
fede don't use pie charts normally I
would say and don't use the default
colors and like this is probably the
most horrible chart and I've ever seen
so far and like there was on TV so
that's just really really bad so I guess
like you can all make something really
much better than that but there's a lot
of like people around them making really
horrible charts like it's quite
difficult to find good examples when
it's just so much looks the same or like
not really that good and like creating a
perfect charge you know like even even
that might not be perfect like there's
always stuff to improve as always just
like personal preference and yeah
depends on you so like I hope you like
learned a lot I put in like tons of
links here like why I got most of the
information of the presentation and also
some more so like if you're interested
in that field yeah like I hope you know
a little bit more now and you're all
excited about using less colors but good
ones for now on thank you yeah thank you
very much I think maybe one question
short one
I think for the talk I just want to know
if you have a fallback in the case of
let's say different beamers sometimes
you go to a conference or you go to any
kind of presentation you have to do and
the Beamer is not trying the good
contrast the colors don't look like well
so then again is there some kind of plan
B 2 or do you already research how those
rooms and beamers look like and even the
size of the Beamer sometimes matters so
like choosing correct sizes I know
that's 2 questions now but yeah Plan B
is the question for that presentation I
didn't but I also didn't have time for
that but in general I guess it's a good
way but I don't don't think many people
have time to like you know like create
different charts for like different
colors but in general it will be really
good to be prepared for those changes so
I guess depends on the audience like if
you have a big audience of people it may
be really good to have different charts
like if you have like you know like
you're like a company presentation that
may be really good to have like
different contrasts colors but they're
like some tools available for contrast
like to choose colors with like a high
contrast for example if you want to show
that so even if the Beamer has not the
best contrast it will probably still
look ok on a big Beamer okay so if you
have more questions I think then there
will be around the conference the next
three days so thank you very much and
thank him again please
[Applause]